having spent the better part of a month
with the xbox series x
preview unit and now about a week with
an official retail build
i've been able to experience the breadth
of what microsoft's next-gen system
offers
i've covered its capabilities in great
detail with two full previews but now
it's time for a full review with the
retail unit
the xbox series x is an impressive piece
of hardware one that flexes its power in
subtle yet meaningful ways but i
wouldn't say it's essential to
transition to the series x at launch
if you're on a 1x but the benefits of
the next-gen hardware
are tangible and you won't want to go
back once you get hands-on
its rdna 2 gpu and zentu cpu from amd
the series x makes a significant
technical leap for current gen games
played through backwards compatibility
this means
unlocking untapped potential that the
one x couldn't leverage
entirely and in some cases series x does
this without any need for optimizations
some games will get inherent performance
boost by virtue of the more powerful
specs
so if a game runs on an unlocked frame
rate or a 60fps cap that it couldn't
always maintain on existing hardware you
will see the game hit those higher frame
rates more consistently and if a game
runs a dynamic resolution it'll be able
to maintain the highest resolutions it's
allowed to hit
previous examples i've used are final
fantasy xv and monster hunter world both
of which have 1x enhancements but not
series x enhancements in final fantasy
15 its performance mode runs a
consistent 60fps and monster hunter
world can do the same
even on the prioritized graphics mode
where the 1x would struggle to maintain
60fps the series x lets these games
reach that potential
sekiro shadow's die twice is probably
one of the best examples of series x
hardware
simply boosting a game's performance to
hit 60fps unlike the xbox one x
this is a case where it genuinely and
meaningfully improves the experience
since sekiro's an intense high-stakes
action game on the flip side an example
of hard-coded limitations in games
final fantasy xv's higher fidelity
options still run at its enforced cap of
30 fps and the same applies to games
like the outer worlds
so don't go in expecting every single
game to be running 4k resolution or
super high frame rates
some games are just made with built-in
resolution or frame rate caps
in those cases it's up to developers if
they want to go back and implement new
optimizations to utilize the new power
afforded by the series
x
[Music]
as for series x optimized games we've
had access to gears 5 gears tactics
forza horizon 4
sea of thieves and yakuza like a dragon
with gears 5
you can boost the frame rate to 120 fps
in multiplayer to take advantage of the
console's 4k 120hz capabilities
if you have the proper display the
enhancements i appreciate more however
come from the increases from 30fps to
60fps while running crispy 4k
such as the case in gears tactics forza
horizon 4 and sea of thieves
they simply run full 4k 60fps as opposed
to the xbox one x graphics options where
you'd have to choose between visuals or
performance
yakuza like dragon is a bit trickier and
you get two options available
high resolution for native 4k 30fps and
normal
for 1440p 60fps while it's likely to be
a case-by-case basis this could be
indicative of where more graphically
demanding games may go for the upcoming
generation
from a technical standpoint although the
changes may not blow you away
these games have been slick experiences
with some noticeable visual improvements
however it's a fairly limited showcase
of the series x's full power we should
expect more substantial enhancements as
more of these optimizations roll out
[Music]
super fast loading is what i think
people will be most impressed by as it
provides a more practical benefit that
makes gaming experiences nearly seamless
the internal nvme ssd does the heavy
lifting and it does so without needing
specific optimizations
the series x can load from the main menu
into gameplay for
red dead redemption 2 for example in
around 30 seconds
games like control final fantasy xv and
the outer worlds load in about 10 to 12
seconds
and gears 5 and gears tactics load into
action in about 5 seconds and 15 seconds
respectively yakuza like dragon can load
into its detailed world
in just 6 seconds these are all vast
improvements over the xbox one x's
internal storage drive that usually took
about four to five times
longer these numbers can start to lose
meaning when rattled off like this but
it can't be understated how much of a
difference the speed makes
fast load times like these have been a
major perk for pc gamers with nvme ssds
and now it's the standard going into the
new console generation
and it's a luxury you can enjoy here
the internal ssd sure is fast but 802
gigabytes of free space on this one
terabyte drive can fill up quickly with
the size of games today if you're
looking at options for expanding storage
the one terabyte seagate expansion card
is the premium
option although it's pricey at 220 bucks
at launch it performs
exactly like the internal drive you can
also use external usb 3 drives to play
backwards compatible games that haven't
been optimized for series x
if they are optimized or series x
specific games you'll have to transfer
them from external storage onto the
internal drive
or expansion card thankfully transfer
speeds are relatively fast over usb3
though that also depends on whether or
not you're using an ssd or a traditional
hard drive
[Music]
those of you who've been using the xbox
one for some time will notice that
things haven't changed all that much
when it comes to the user interface
navigation is much snappier on the
series x but it maintains the overall
look and feel which i personally don't
mind since it works well enough
what really brings that snappy
navigation into its own is the quick
resume
feature it's one of the highlights of
using the xbox series x you can have
around five to six game states suspended
and jump between those games
without having to reboot them all you do
is hit the home button and switch to
another game and quick resume takes care
of the rest it's built into how the
system operates
quick resume retains those suspended
states after turning off the console and
even after unplugging the power cord
now not everyone will jump between that
many games but it's really convenient
for hopping into the ones that you're
frequently playing
it's had some hiccups during the review
process with rare occasions of freezing
while trying to jump back into a game
the hope is that these issues can be
resolved if and when they do come up
because quick resume has a real benefit
for the way i play games just be aware
that the system doesn't communicate when
quick resume reaches its upper limit
though
along with the series x package is a
revised controller it doesn't stray too
far from the xbox one design but
features nice tactile textures on the
grips and triggers a crunchy 8-way d-pad
and a dedicated share button that lets
you take screenshots or record short
clips on the fly
you can also choose which resolution it
records in but that also dictates how
long these clips can be
as for the console design itself yeah it
has that thick brick aesthetic but it's
a simple and clean look
what's more important is that the system
has been whisper quiet throughout my
entire experience
and really you don't need to worry about
heat as long as you give the top fan
enough space to vent
so overall the xbox series x is a
fantastic console that still has a ton
of potential to unlock
until console exclusive games come out
you won't necessarily be gated from
accessing any content
xbox is offering holding off until you
start seeing more games make the most of
the system's potential
is a fair and smart move and nothing
really screams out as a killer app for
the series x right now
but it's also worth considering that
buying a console is an investment for
your gaming future
and not just for what's available here
and now and at least what we've seen
thus far is an enticing showcase
of series x's capabilities it's an
extremely refined xbox and a great piece
of tech that sets a strong foundation
for microsoft to better serve its
console users
at least right now the future looks
bright for the xbox platform
with the series x
you